you
all righty it's a created tournament
trust network arena 52 players let's see
what we get
what an adjustment from three Oh time
control I not jump in there straight
away
alright let's run it like this do
something a little crazy super committal
light squares are all mine I think let's
just go here first that night could be a
pretty big pest
let's insist
maeín too if you take my pawn breaking
down the light squares oh I can take
that guy whatever no night there
Wow why did I run it like this man
I should have just captured when I had
the chance
my bishop should be pretty strong though
know who get out of there
give me that phone
you were tuned
no Forks no please no careful don't end
up in a pin you ended up in a pin
Oh No don't you do it watch out for the
sneakiness geekiness
got this one
10 seconds back to turn
all right Oh opera wasn't don't give me
too much of a beating man don't do it I
already blundered I'm giving myself a
beating
all right I need my see fund I'm playing
this like a type of boat
[Music]
take the rook c1 okay
I need a flight square still I'm just
going to build up
cheese speedy man speedy and down now
two pawns and down on time
oh my
third pond and here goes the clean
this Abbey
you
alright i allowing my queen to get
active like this
it's really weird to see them
activity
Oh down on time and position
out I have to play really good chess
against that guy all good penguins in
there - all right
there's a lot of
Aires with fire and I'm not one of them
here we go nice and steady you have
plenty of time
oh look at that free Bishop jump in the
center there should be seven damage the
structure get on the main diagonal where
does my knight want to be f4 keep the
bishop clean d7 I really don't care
about that phone
mates rook takes phone start throwing
pawns at my opponent Knight moves mate
no I would have been a bad one then I
could play here let's take here
made on each one King has to run he
didn't run
that's mate back to turn
all right I have four on page three okay
24 minutes on the nose here we go
now let's not take just yet to play to
play stronger
play a little bit stronger okay they're
speeding up my development take care and
I'm going to be a little sneaky defend
that phone
night before I just back up
really weakening before but I don't want
my knight chased away
so now forget about it I
giving up on the Greek gift stuff
I was ready to do this instead of rookie
one you're running into some serious
trouble maybe I could still shoot for
this stuff let's go here I don't like
that my opponents playing so aggressive
you need to stop that okay let's try it
now I have a couple different rook lifts
and how are they stopping mate now rook
moves I take here first throw look on
the h-file next let's go this rook
yeah that's me back to turn got 622 in
change who's in first 14 penguin je
posthumous lab Aryan upper resin okay
got to get this win got to get my first
four
here we go Benoni
here we go
oh yeah
give up the darks permission
go clean D - let's see 94 I have three
minor pieces there
I h-bar
how about we scare him away and then
strike at4 not sure what I'm doing with
my night now that the bishop isn't there
I could play Knight h5 knight on g3 is
pretty strong what about Bishop d7 rook
c8 c4 could win upon do like this we're
going to get this guy there dark square
Bishop is very valuable
just drop the bishop Queen g5 next main
threat it should take
Knight takes h3
let's just keep it real
simple
give the material back for some
simplicity
think I'm getting a piece out of rook at
a time edge and another piece they
resigned back to tournament okay page
one got ten which fire 18 14 12 12 I'm
in there 10
all righty clean master right on my
heels with 10j posh Booma
okay
no no if I wanted to be like what's uh
okay let's open it up now
oh I'm not winning that
is calculated I am on I am on c7 so
and you get something
all righty chase that night away and I
need to get rid of who do this try to
make them struggle a little bit more to
hump up on down
the night moves I take here with check
[Music]
you
can i sideline that night
you
you
oh here they're on my rook ah anything
but that
I like
move out easily
man
you
hahaha well flipped away oh that darn
night man I hate those nights when they
land forks against me oh man anything
but that I was fighting back I don't
know what Knight takes e5 was ah why
give your opponent a piece
I was thinking after rook takes on d8
there was one less defender there but
there was still enough defense all right
I think I might need to berserk some
might whoa need to get a quick win we
might just have that here
on the rook gonna play this one out
anything
you
run keep pushing up on another one
now I kind of just captured
anything though
you
got the bishop
so check no stalemate
they resigned back to term
well
okay
fire only 1/4 need more force
4s are hard to come by 94 in here efore
once with f5 let's grab some space okay
hang on to him
and him like at that
we're going to sneak right in here that
night should be a monster monster night
let's give a check another check another
check where's the mate don't drop your
queen man don't do it
on man
on the bishop
check the makes there it is back to
German
okay page one can I stay on page 130 420
420 got 14 right about the halfway point
let's go with e4 again let's try to mix
this one up
let's grab some
space night here I'm doing a sack
and now we're going to key into some
light squares let's throw this guy down
quick mate not so fast huh okay
there are bishop
quiet there's Bishop takes pawn cleanup
two ideas almost non-slip Bishop f4
council I never take the beep on
probably could have oh the Queen and
resigned
going back to Turin I got 18 which fire
okay
there we go let's challenge the dark
square bishop he's really strong
stop 95 the h-file
let's play like this each to take my
pone yes
that was a quick win back to tournament
38 24 22 is he's slipping up against
penguin
would have been my guess all right
so Queenie - let's get a flight square
useful move let's take one let's get a
flight square now
take take
all right I have to
the square
I would have been something
defendi for
okay I'm on the Queen there isn't time
for that let's go here on the Queen and
now this
okay my queen is really strong she's
tough to dislodge night here next
oh no this is kind of scary now
you
have a check to pick up the bishop
you
he gave that piece back on purpose
so I can move a little faster
they're down on time
okay 42 27 26
oh
boy
steamer I got to get you back somehow
somehow
okay I'll take I guess
all major pieces the
decision EF is this a liability or an
asset somebody tell me
we're going to find out I don't want to
enter that kind of an endgame
they moved
and see it certainly didn't hear it
over here
you
pick up that phone okay I think I
have this now yeah I think I know how to
win this now I'll defend him
I had this idea now I could offer rook
exchanges get here next improve my king
let's do this now two slides the King
check and I have everything supported
now don't blunder your ruff there isn't
a tricky night now I should be able to
time burn uh-huh okay
and they resigned back to tournament
okay forty six thirty nine thirty less
than eight left
eighty-eight in here
all right
am I going to get hit with the penguin
or the oppor wasn't someone else spirit
of gamer
you got a mover
nine or EF
then I don't see six should have played
Queen b6 first just going to hurt me
hitting b2
queen
and v2 let's just open this up
let's push push again try
but closed I cleans defending this pawn
I want to get rid of that night
takes and then
again takes bishop step mic hang up whoo
honey would be a million - there would
be a million - if I capture there the
knight takes f6
let's get rid of this knife before he
kills me
that's important my Queens guarding that
you
down on time back to turn
eat on me there 50 okay 50 39:34
let's try another I could take here
there's no direct shot at my night and
it could take you now
and challenge their night straightaway
let's just bring it back
there how about we see in kiddo
knight on e5 put some pressure on c4 and
rook c8 b v b4 Queen d7 take with the
knight now let's take with the rook
let's push him around you didn't go
anywhere
some hunt this pond down
clean on f4 take this pawn takes pawn
one of these two
take their here here
the rook in the end back to tournament
all right 50 to 40 38 it's possible I
could get second penguin just getting
paired up with operas and beating him I
[Laughter]
have fire less than four
oh really
giving up the dark square bishop like
that
my opponent
for doing this
should be
punished
that move was pretty good
take
I think it rid of that night I think I
need my C pawn to contribute c4 and then
Bishop b4 I don't want them to have a
tsunami of pawns in the center
c4 Bishop b4 Bishop f4 95 maybe a rook
lift
really thinking this one through what's
happening 20 seconds left
why aren't they moving twelve seconds
ten seconds we going to get one more
game in okay that was weird
okay well if I win this one I think I
could sneak up in two seconds penguin is
playing against Repton am I going to get
paired with upper Wesen two minutes five
seconds let's see who we get taking a
while for this parent come on just pair
me up I want to be able to get this game
in at least have a chance
All Right game on this may come down to
I'd have a bit of a buzzer beater here
just grabbed upon at the rook
is winning
you
and simply the king
cancel out that night
okay
let's get shelter for my king
that's me yes doctor tournament I have a
one-point lead come on just and now just
end oh oh I could no no frying my way to
victory I could at the very least view
the no no fry tactic ah it's always nice
to have that tactic I can know to fry I
could known a fry if I want
yes
let's get a flight square afraid of some
kind of pond push and then rip the eight
let's get active on the pond and a bit
of a pin
you
hmmm interesting looking pond and game
very interesting
hmm I'm going to hunt that pond down
really passive now yeah yeah I'm cooked
great
you
kind of go after that pun try to draw
this
can they get that fun
you
who
check oh I don't know to do
oh I had my chance
oh what an ending oh man I just had to
make moves I was trying to find best
moves in that final position did I have
something there he's trying to find a
check there King there no I didn't have
a check
I needed to move
Oh point two seven it's got the hundreds
what a tournament all right well I took
second but I think that had a real lot
to do with I don't know
the pairing system I only had two games
against topper wasn't and he had how
many games against penguin one two three
yeah lucky to even be in second all
right in the end there were 107 what a
cool ending and that was a cool game all
right
good games oh yeah thanks two of those
that came out for this one has a good
turn on in
penguin first I too
second copper was in third
and fourth was in there with 33 let's
see all the pages real quick
page 2 3 4 5 6 7 almost there
all righty good games all